welcome to Table Talk where each week I
unpack insights from Christian theology
and spirituality that help you become a
thoughtful contemplative and downright
great human being and coming episodes
I'm gonna be doing a series of sorts on
relationships and how to handle conflict
of course a very small percentage of the
population revels and conflict occur
most of us spend our lives avoiding it
like the plague and of course that's a
huge mistake so today I'd like to give
you three reasons that relational
conflict is actually a good thing
number one when handled well conflict
creates trust not trauma
now we fear trauma which is why we run
from conflict right we don't want to
hurt people's feelings and we don't want
to have our feelings hurt so you ask
okay well like how on earth can conflict
create trust well a because people can
see that you're being honest with them
of course that doesn't mean in the
moment they'll be like thank you so much
this is truly fantastic but it doesn't
mean that a day or two later they'll
realize you know I appreciate that they
were straightforward with me it's better
that way
all right so that's a B it creates trust
because when you address the issue
calmly and maturely again you don't
freak out it communicates to the other
person this is someone who I can build
with they won't run when times get tough
they're willing to go through this with
me that builds trust a few months back I
had a situation with a friend where I
really hurt their feelings
had been honest with them I've been
avoiding conflict but one day it all
came out and I made assumptions that
true and I hurt them and I thought it's
just might be it that's the game folks
turn off the lights but no they didn't
run they said look I pissed and hurt but
I'm here let's work through this and can
you see how that actually built trust
for me for us right so that's the first
reason conflict is actually a good thing
we're handled well
it creates trust not trauma right the
second reason it's actually a good thing
is that conflict grows deepens and
matures me all right I think spiritual
practices like prayer fasting scripture
reading journaling solitude etc are
essential for growing and deepening
ourselves however what can often be
overlooked in emphasizing those is the
fact that daily life is a powerful
teacher when you're in conflict with
someone and your heart is beating and
your mind is racing it's not a moment to
run from it's a moment to say this will
be the testing ground of Who I am and
everything I say I believe God and life
are trying to teach me something now how
specifically this conflict grow deepen
and mature us well it teaches us to face
hard things rather than running
I had a friend he was scheduled an
appointment to talk with me and so she
sat down and began to unpack the story
of how she just left her previous job
because she saw some unethical things
happening and you know she's pretty sure
her boss knows in fact she was like 99%
sure but she didn't really say anything
so she just quietly resigned and I
well were you honest with your boss
about why you left and she said no and I
said well you should schedule an
appointment and do that and she said but
I hate conflict and that's so scary I
said well here's the thing like you need
to learn to grow right and I suspect
this isn't the only area of your life
where you're avoiding conflict and right
then she hung her head and she said yeah
you're right I'll do it and so I texted
her for weeks saying I talked to form
boss yet like have you talked to Vasya
and finally she did and afterwards she
came to me and she said thank you so
much I needed to grow in this area see
conflict it grows it matures it deepens
us alright third conflict groves deepens
in matures those around me all right as
farms 27 and verse 6 says faithful are
the wounds of a friend but the kisses of
an enemy are deceitful you see honest
conflict is the wound of a friend it's
me inviting them to face themselves
it's me holding up a mirror if only for
a moment so they can see themselves and
when viewed through this lens conflict
becomes a tremendous opportunity to
deepen the relationship rather than a
sign of its inevitable demise so that's
three reasons conflict is actually a
good thing
well that's all for today if you like
this video please click the like button
and comment below and if you know
someone who could really use this
content go ahead and share with them
grace and peace